hola que tal buenas tardes básicamente
la fiscalía estuvo durante nueve días
llevando adelante su alegato en el que
fue presentando diferentes tipos de
prueba de todo tipo documental también
algunas conversaciones telefónicas que
pudieron presentar a lo largo de este
periodo y ellos consideran que allí está
aprobado dos delitos el de defraudación
a la administración pública y el de
asociación ilítica ilícita estos dos
delitos permiten penas incluso mayores a
los 12 años y también este pedido de
inhabilitación para el ejercicio de
cargos públicos por eso a puntarenas y
una una aclaración importante si puedo
hacer que la función canina está
profundamente polarizada y quienes son
cercanos a la vicepresidenta que la
siguen consideran que la fiscalía está
totalmente equivocada y la causa es si
se quiere hasta inventada pero quienes
están del otro lado y que no pueden ver
con buenos ojos a la expresidente actual
vicepresidenta consideran que no hay
dudas de que la fiscalía está en lo
cierto entonces es un gran desafío este
caso para la justicia argentina y que
sigue ahora en el proceso para la
vicepresidenta
se terminaron los alegatos de la
fiscalía y ahora a partir del 5 de
septiembre comienzan los alegatos de las
defensas recordemos que son en total
tres imputados esos tres imputados van a
poder presentar sus defensas y luego
vendrá el momento en este contexto de
juicio oral en el que el tribunal deberá
decidir si se le da la razón a las
defensas oa la fiscalía pero no va a
terminar allí porque seguramente
cualquiera sea el resultado la parte que
se vea menos beneficiada e intentará
hacer algún tipo de nueva instancia en
casación para ver si se puede cambiar un
potencial veredicto incluso llevarlo a
la corte suprema de justicia así que
estamos hablando de meses y tal vez
hasta años hasta que se defina hay
elecciones en el 2023 presidenciales
algunos sugieren que se quiere
prescribir a la ex presidenta para que
no pueda presentarse pero la realidad es
que los tiempos parecen indicar que eso
no podría suceder antes de las
elecciones de 2023